one of the techniques or one of the
topics regarding dialogue interest me
that I think that I saw you talk about
was a dumping dialogue versus just kind
of like real dialogue so dumping of
information that's correct but yeah just
sort of like giving everybody everything
they need right then and there and it's
too much it's not breathing it's not
natural doesn't all right so how can
someone slow down without sort of just
giving the reader or the audience too
much information
well the first thing you have to
understand about dialogue is that it's
got to be connected to the characters
desire line in the scene in other words
if a character has an objective
intention in the scene the dialogue has
to match that intention and what I see a
lot of times especially with exposition
and information is that a character is
saying all that information and you can
tell that it's really the writers
objective and where's the writer wants
to wants the audience to know this
information because they think okay the
audience needs to know this and this and
it's amiss so the characters going to
say this in interest and that doesn't
work because scenes and dialogue are
about a character's intention in the
scene
everything a character says is matched
to what that desire line is so anything
that doesn't belong to that doesn't fit
and you can tell whether it's the writer
of wanting to that information is
wanting the audience in line information
whether it's part of the character um I
was trying to think of an example um so
one of the best questions you can ask
yourself for every single line of
dialogue in your scene so write the
dialogue first draft just do what you
want to do don't worry about that but
when you reread the dialogue ask
yourself for every line why is that
character sending this why is the
character saying that specific line most
of the time will be because they're
responding to us so they're reacting to
something that's fine but a lot of the
times you will find that a character is
saying something
you want the character to say that not
because the character wants something in
that scene at a specific time so you've
got to know what the character ones and
then every line of dialogue is a
strategy for that character to get what
they want and if that dialogue is not
that then you rewrite the line until it
fits that now exposition there's ways to
make sure the expositions and your
dialogue matches the objective for
example if you know I'm suspected of
murder and you're you're the you know
detective who's asking me questions
right and tell me where were you and I
didn't commit the murder
well whatever I'm going to say is my
desire to make you think I didn't do the
murder so there's a there's a reason why
I'm saying that line I didn't do it I
was at the movies saying at the movies
is exposition but it's connected to my
desire to convince you that I was not
the killer you see so the exposition
matches the objective of the character
you know so there's ways to do this
display museum this techniques to make
sure the exposition is settled you know
part of a part of conflict part of your
desire line etc so there's a lot of
stuff you could do but that's the lesson
you really have to know that's the
that's the most important thing make
sure you know what every character wants
in the scene make sure that what they
say matches that objective so I always
bring out David Mamet was you know
genius its dialogue and he said once
nobody says anything unless they want
something so unless you want something
nobody says anything because nobody's
going to say you know hey I'm a
trustworthy character right I mean what
somebody said that to you you know
you're going to be thinking oh why is he
telling me this right there's always a
reason why so there's always a reason
and if we know what the reason is in a
movie if you know what the character
wants or you trying to figure out what
the character one that's more
interesting than somebody dumping
exposition you know characters would
just dump exposition it's just boring
because it's not it's not connected to a
desert
even characters who disagree with each
other even though that might be kind of
interesting because there's some tension
there
if we don't know what they want it's
going to be boring so you see you see
this a lot of damage Racine's of people
like oh I need conflict so my character
is just going to argue and so you have
people arguing back and forth but it
doesn't doesn't mean anything it's just
fine because we don't know what they
want that's really what makes something
interesting is intention and possible to
that we talked earlier about dumbing
things down which this is a different
way of talking about it but in terms of
let's suppose it's a doctor speaking to
another doctor but they're not going to
say they're not going to use doctor
lingo exactly and they may they may see
something that's grammatically incorrect
they may use slang they may know long
they may write it's not going to be the
surprise perfect it depends on the
character okay I like to I like to talk
a lot about contrast so you have two
characters in the scene is really more
interesting if the characters are
contrasted so if a character is speaking
in a formal way so somebody with an
academic or a professor or doctor and
you speak in a formal way make sure that
the person that is interacting with
speaks in a more slanging way or you
know more contracted way because that's
going to make you're gonna create that
contrast you know the fact in painting
if you you want to highlight the color
blue you surround it with yellow right
it's opposite so it's the same thing
with characters a lot of techniques in
the dialogue chapter in the book are
about individuality how do you create
individual voices because having all the
characters sound the same is a very
common problem with dialogue it's
usually the writers voice and you know
and you know Sorkin is actually been
criticized for that that all these
characters sound the same but you know
what I want to talk about his dialogue
and I show clips and actual scripts you
can show that you know he actually does
individualize and the characters sound
different so it's an unfair criticism
but um but you have to do that you know
it helps if if there's
you know different in character speech
or cadence or contractions versus you
know
stilted writing grammatically correct
finding what the characters speak to
themselves what if they're thinking out
loud what if they're looking in the
mirror whatever they're berating
themselves right because it's really a
character thing as long as you keep it
short you know I mean the problem I see
is when it's too long you know then
we're kind of wonder okay words or it's
the conflict or is what's happening here
I mean it might be interesting but but
you know even something that's really
interesting for too long will disengage
an audience after a while so don't you
could do it just don't do it for too
long
you